at 11 points and seven rebounds in that
game back in Phoenix we play junior
shits his defender is the MU Bray gets
tied up they forced the turnover and
George racing out able to lay it up and
in and he's accelerated Stark's is wood
right box now 1 for 4 to open up all of
his shots outside the pink George the
gray the cut
the last five shots they lead by 517 to
12
George chased by a junior the deflection
there by the sun's turn over Clippers
their fourth Rubio to the rim he's
clever and he lives today
active hands would speed you can get out
in transition early for your team George
cradles the ball down that hatchet goes
for fall two new great seniors swipes it
away
leather city brings it back the other
way count it and a foul new great
seniors swipes it away leather city
brings it back the other way
count it and a foul on Tommy W Bray jr.
can play he plays with a ton of energy
and when you play with energy and
toughness you find ways to score the
basketball we all know that Kelly old
over it is very very athletic but now
he's using that a little bit later with
time but I am Armani Williams
I love money Paul George knocks in the
jumper he's got a team high 12 jump set
inside the zoo BOTS
blocked at the peak of asleep by you
bring junior gets his first rebound
throws it away
[Applause]
finishes with the room
[Music]
throws it away George gets it back with
blue Krait divinity flushes an ad and
stares them down after the flush
they're both even say they're even at
Paul George is showing the Clippers how
to dunk the basketball a and pg-13 you
see right there early
Kelly downloaded um okay they want to
play a little tub and PG spas to play D
Prince and kill you anyway
finishes mixed on that play and you can
see right away they're talking and all
of a sudden PG say oh man I'm a good
chewed up and put you in the room